and half I'm so jealous you have all
these beautiful women seven girlfriends
personally I think it's awesome awesome
that you sleep with seven women because
they would be ostentatious
but look on the bright side ladies you
don't have to sleep on a wet spot once a
week
[Music]
look at this place Tony Curtis Jack
Carter red buttons I've seen younger
faces on cash
this isn't a roast it's a rot
Melinda Carlisle from the Go-Go's I love
you
I love you
I love the way you're dressed like a
hooker from Battlestar Galactica
and look how beautiful Playmate Holly
Madison looks tonight wow
yeah
you do very well on this show every time
the director yelled action he started
taking her clothes off
this is all right nice to see him
thanks for having me you know I uh I was
so excited to be here and see Shaq and
Emma and hang out with all these
comedians I feel like I died and went to
Harlem
yeah
this ain't a roast it's a barbecue
and one of the girls explain to me half
why you have seven women you know one to
put it in and the other six to move you
around
face and Shack you are gigantic
that suit is bigger than the one against
Harvey Weinstein
you look very lovely today thank you you
have blacker roots and Kunta Kinte
foreign
being able to take a joke is so
important in life exactly it's all about
smiling and laughing especially with an
outfit like that
love you good luck with the lipstick on
your teeth you're awesome
all right see you at home how is it
possible that Courtney Love looks worse
than Kurt Cobain
what
all the good things that Jerry Lewis
does people always make fun of them but
what about the good things that he does
what about the fact that just last Labor
Day a six-year-old kid got up out of his
wheelchair and walked for the very first
time
to turn off the Jerry Lewis Telethon
look at you what's your name
Melissa you're almost [ __ ]
oh my God look at that your balls are
hanging down your skirt
how about a hand for your host Larry
King everybody thanks pal
you always say nice things about me
we've done a few of these together and
you're always a little less funny each
time
this isn't a roast but if it was a roast
ladies and gentlemen I would say Larry
King is the comedy with Martin Luther
King is to Comedy
give it up for our guests of honor the
four hosts of Inside the NBA Shaquille
O'Neal
Charles Barkley
the other black guy
and the guy who's dressed for an
impeachment
but Emmett you know I'm here for
basically two reasons first reason is
I'm a big big fan of yours second reason
is Shaq sent me a beautiful letter
saying he wanted me to come and it was
for charity and I knew it was really
from Shaq because it was signed to
s-h-a-c-k
foreign
just for the record I think it's kind of
hypocritical you care so much about
animal rights since you've been
torturing your own Beaver for years
Norm you're dressing like you're going
to help somebody move
you're wearing sweatpants to the biggest
show in YouTube history this is the
biggest show on the internet you dress
like you're gonna paint the set
you can't help himself seriously all
kidding aside it's nice to be here at
the Hollywood Wax Museum
foreign
about the boyish good looks of Larry
King
or as Ted Turner calls him the Hunchback
of CNN
poor Larry is Hebrew name is yeah
this is the face that made Ellen gay
all right
I wanted to check out your office
wow this is it's like Trump built a wall
around just you
know from Kiss one of my greatest uh
childhood Idols Ace Frehley is here
makeup looks like Dr Joyce Brothers with
makeup
growing up I loved basketball but I was
never very good at it Kenny Smith you
can relate right
how you doing babe
what's going on with you
not much who you here with
you oh my God look at you wow I wouldn't
[ __ ] you with his dick
Larry all kidding aside you're married
again your wife is gorgeous you're gonna
be a uh she's gonna have your grandson
in a couple of months and uh
Shaq man you look good you look good
congratulations you're you're uh your
knuckles have scrape did you walk here
thank you
[Applause]
oh hi
how you doing
I'm Jeff
how you doing Elise wow knock knock
who's there your absentee father
surprise
you do yeah you're like a stripper who
hates money so you work here
those shorts are shorter than the amount
of time you spent in high school wow
look at this office
this is amazing
is this where the Rams were supposed to
play
anyway
I love the way your boobs bounce up and
down
taco salad
actually Kenny Smith played on the same
college team as Michael Jordan and
that's where the comparison ends
how you doing sir I'm sir ma'am I'm not
really sure what it is
are you okay I love you on the cover of
Mad Magazine
[Applause]
Max you have the biggest boobs on this
stage right now do you realize that
[Music]
what do you do here I do calcium casting
wow you're like Amy Winehouse if she
went to rehab
all right
buttons is going to be coming up in a
short while the man I worship a living
legend everybody read buttons
a man has been doing comedy so long he's
his own influence
John Mcenroe is here to make sure nobody
has a good time
[Music]
Cheryl teags
watch for her upcoming nude spread in
AARP magazine
foreign
God bless you sir I don't know if you
remember this but the first time I I saw
red buttons was uh back in New York I
was walking around downtown and uh you
never know what you're going to see in
New York I saw I saw red buttons in an
antique shop
800 bucks and uh
great to see you
Johnny Depp I really congratulations I
hear your divorce is officially you're
finally divorced from uh bathing
apparently oh how you doing Josh oh look
a Jewish comedy writer who would have
guessed it
Jeff how do you know he's Jewish huh how
do you know he's Jewish I looked at him
how you doing great wow
wow who are you supposed to be Peter
sleeps in a Parker yeah I
was wondering what happened to Courtney
Love yeah
fantastic how's business today business
is uh you know it's been pretty good my
Spidey senses tell me you're gonna make
four dollars today
oh
you told me to wake you up when you hit
rock bottom
foreign
[Applause]
Shaq you take more bad shots than Jason
Williams
is he here
then [ __ ] him
[Applause]
no I'm teasing you Shaq you know that
you were great in The Green Mile
you guys also have a rich criminal
history in this town you had the Boston
Tea Party here
Whitey Bulger was from here Tom Brady's
from here
wouldn't really let the air out of the
room huh
met your movies are bad man
look at me all right stop making movies
now memorize that and repeat it to Rick
Fox
are you here then [ __ ] them
does anybody ever get offended by your
tattoo
anyway good luck with the rest of your
stay in jail how many years 99 dude you
should get six million years for every
Jew that died in the Holocaust
man
crack that coffee coffee table
[Music]
wow thanks Kanye West you having a good
time Michael uh what do you mean I'm
having a great time all right well tell
your facelift
[Laughter]
I like your shirt I didn't realize you
were a pharmacist during the day
you went too far
stop talking
[Applause]
[Applause]